luke beasley here filling in for david
while he's away on paternity leave we
have a fascinating story to talk about
so as has been wildly covered over the
last few years amazon's work environment
is pretty horrible and there's been a
lot of stories revealed about people not
being able to go to the restroom
properly like they're driving down the
road and they have so little time that
they're expected to do something that
they're
going to the restroom you know in their
car in a bag or something
being expected to do way too much and
not being treated correctly for it and
one of the reasons that this work
environment was the way that it was was
actually sort of intentional
amazon higher ups had designed it where
you get pushed so hard that there's no
way you're going to stay very long and
they're okay with that they're gonna
have a really high turnover rate but
then while you're there extract as much
work as possible and not treat you the
way that you should be treated so they
go through a massive amount of employees
each month and each year who just go in
they go out they go in they go out and
they grind them down so aggressively and
so quickly so besides public pressure it
was actually working for the higher-ups
you know if you think from the
perspective that we're getting a lot of
work out of these people
and
making huge um profits until now and
this is wild reading from yahoo finance
amazon's no frill low wage high turnover
labor model is beginning to show signs
of stress the tech giant could run out
of workers to hire for its warehouses by
2024 according to a leaked amazon
internal research memo
from mid-2021 seen by the publication
recode
putting its service quality growth plans
and quick labor churn model in a pinch
if we continue business as usual amazon
will deplete the available labor supply
in the u.s network by 2024 the leaked
report indicated so because they push
their workers so hard they're literally
going to be in a situation where at all
these given warehouses
all the vicinity around where they can
hire from aren't going to have enough
employees potential employees who are
within the you know type of employee
that would work that particular position
who haven't already left amazon is that
insane
so what is their solution well reading
again from yahoo finance the memo said
amazon had six levers it could use to
delay the labor crisis by a few years
including raising wages and increasing
automation but the only way to
significantly alter this timeline is to
make sweeping changes to the way it
manages its employees so
obviously automation could possibly help
them with this take away some of the
jobs that they need but it's not going
to do it all and so i love how they
stumbled into what we've been all
screaming at them for a long time now
you're one of the biggest corporations
in the world you make tons of money you
can afford to pay your workers correctly
and treat them correctly
and
it's crazy because they are just now
realizing hey if we want people to work
here do we have to not abuse them do we
have to be decent to them is that
something that we have to do
yes
unbelievable um well i hope that they go
in this direction of course and
treat all the workers the way that they
deserve to be treated
wish they could have figured this out
earlier but we'll take it now